governor good morning how are you good
you in that cool studio Danna yeah yeah
it's a cool studio for those who have
never been there just line up outside
he'll serve coffee and doughnuts you
could all go in a thick picture pretty
safe studio princy says you have some
things you want to get off your chest so
I'm here sorry I have one thing that
I've been complaining about for quite a
long time and I know our our Indians are
in the in the World Series but dan I
think the baseball is going to die and
I'm going to tell you why I think so
look you know in the in the NFL in the
NBA they have figured out a way that if
you're not a giant town you can still be
competitive because they figure out a
way to share the revenue so I actually
asked a friend of mine Cincinnati to put
some numbers together of the top 15
teams in payroll 14 of them had a
winning record of the bottom 15 teams in
payroll 13 had a losing record of it of
the 10 playoff teams nine of them came
from the top 14 payrolls in one came
from the bottom 16 now Isis to be still
a man oh dude agree i'm now governor of
ohio but i was born and raised at
Pittsburgh when I was there you know we
could root for players over an extended
period of time down in Cincinnati when
Johnny Cueto comes up they got a trade
of the year before I don't know I don't
even know who he's playing for anymore
Sanford because you can't afford to pay
these these players and I understand
that you look at a Theo Epstein or
whatever and how smart he is in baseball
he's also as a hundred million dollar
extra mount in payroll for the Cubs than
they have for the Reds and the Indians
are in the same spot I mean it takes you
know these these guys can sneak in but
it's really really hard when everything
is stacked against you and these owners
are unwilling to actually cut a fair
deal and what I worry about then with
America's greatest pastime which may be
past its time
is that we're going to see it in the big
cities and you know across the heartland
of the country in these small towns it's
gonna fade away you know everybody to
root for anymore right that your team is
out your team is out before the all-star
break and I don't know why you know I
talked to my buddy Bob Castellini one of
the owners of the Reds I said you guys
are you want to get five or six or seven
of these small market teams and you
ought to hold up the season for a few
games and get somebody's attention does
this is not good for us because baseball
is great and I'm afraid it's gonna it's
going to just dwindle and we're not
going to see it all across this great
country what do you think of that well
we do have good story i mean the indians
are a good story I know that Chicago has
spent money Chicago will have a hard
time keeping all those kids together in
the next couple of years but you had
kansas city that made it to the World
Series Pittsburgh I didn't I know I know
but it's not often i mean just take a
look at the statistics i just gave you
of course in any point in time where was
Kansas City this year where's Pittsburgh
it took 20 years for Pittsburgh to get
in the playoff position they have to
trade most of their players and now
they're out again look at the Reds mean
they pay they pay a guy uh you know at
one guy a ton of money jovan right and
then yet Votto and that to hold the rest
of the players and the Cubs I think with
at least a hundred million dollars more
in payroll than the Reds have a lot
better chance of keeping that team
together which is what they say in
Chicago I was just there yesterday you
know they think you're in for the long
run mean can the Indians that I you know
fall the Indians as well and I call the
owner every years deer head and call
them it you know how's it looking that's
looking good if this will hold up metal
ho up yeah it's hard and I just am
saying that uh you know coming from a
place like Pittsburghers Cincinnati or
Cleveland or even Kansas City you know
it's just not it's not fair and I think
we'll lose a fan base and is happening
well I I just think I understand these
owners you know in football is one guy
told me George Halas and the rooneys and
all that said hey we're all in this
together let's share revenue why do they
share it in everything else but not
baseball
well I think we've tried to get there is
revenue sharing if you overspend than
women yes but there is some you know the
Commissioner was trying to do that and
he said you'll see some of these smaller
markets do better which which turned out
to be the case but yeah I don't like
somebody just saying and I can spend a
hundred million dollars more than you
boy we're a great franchiser I'm a great
GM I I would like to see it more leveled
and then find out really who is great at
their job but yeah right right right is
that what you're trying to say yeah I
like the NBA or like the NFL I think
you've got these one-horse town that
they have NFL teams and they're just as
competitive as anybody else's if there's
it but if it's like in politics and
fundraising he cannot spend ten to one
oh yeah you can win but most the time
you can but why don't we have a salary
cap for that governor but why is it that
you know how much money that you raised
you know can affect who's going to get
elected you're either good or you're no
I think it's a very flawed system you
know dad it's a very flawed system and I
can't figure out nor can anybody else I
talk to figure out the best way to fix
it but it needs six cuz money matters
too much in politics and the more you
have the better you do then the more
sometimes the more you get you get the
money and then you I never have but
sometimes people feel well you know low
obligation here there which is crap but
it's that's life and no i think that
system needs to be fixed i I'm talking
about politics I was like I was in
Chicago yesterday and they were ribbing
me and all that stuff you know here's
the great thing though about base for
about these playoffs right now if you
think about it we have this presidential
campaign where everybody's ripping off
each other's heads right yeah but then
when you're in a bar in Chicago will a
bar in cleveland or you're standing
outside the stadium and somebody hits a
home run and you win the game or you
take the lead nobody says that a guy
next to them with a woman next to them
are you a liberal are you a conservative
you at Democrat you they just all hug
day hug they're so happy about something
in common maybe we got to figure out how
to get that attitude in this
presidential campaign and in politics
going yeah it's too late for the
governor really row well I mean for this
campaign did you imagine saying you know
who are you voting but we got people
they were red and they wear blue we're
not a red or a blue country we're a red
white blue country and we got to stop
fighting with one another and if we look
at sports it's that it's the thing that
brings everybody together so remarkable
isn't it who you voting for haven't
decided but I'm not voting for Trump or
clip I made I may write you in there you
get you're looking good on NBC do you
feel like how about let me ask you about
this okay okay so what about this this
Warriors team what are you saying um
well they 173 last year they added
Durant and I said that they wouldn't
come close to 73 that I thought that if
they won 66 or 67 that was going to be a
great season if you said you could take
golden state of the field I'd take the
field so how do you how do you feel
about that for you you don't think
Durant you don't think Durant absent
well of course we're Cleveland he's
going to hear from ya I mean he's going
to help them eventually but it's going
to take a while to get around to it I
want to give you one more thing because
I'm up against a commercial break here I
doubt I talked to last couple of days
about the the Indians logo there had
never been big on it I don't think
you're depicting you know Native
Americans and it's a cartoon I have a
problem with it whether they change it
or not where do you stand on the Indians
mascot I'm not found absolutely not for
change in it come on Dan it's
embarrassing looking thing well I know
but not embarrassing to us forget it
yeah no I don't agree it's a card to
learn it's a cartoon I don't agree we're
not saying you can do it in the end you
could be wrote more respectfully when
Anna how about Cleveland Republican
convention world series of the Indians
the Cavs it's amazing isn't it and and
job growth in Cleveland it's a whole new
city I here after the convention people
were saying to their spouse if we're
going to go on vacation it's either mah
honey which one do you want to go there
okay if you good then lately
more if you could have a high Oh state
win Cleveland go back to back or the
Indians win the World Series oh look i
know i pod for all three what are you
kidding me you gotta pick one or that's
you're gonna pick well I i don't know i
don't have to pick fun I'm the governor
you're just you can't tell me what the
doodle good LeBron beat you right now if
he ran for governor oh no question no
question he could by the way speaking of
free agents you know I was once the MVP
of the congressional baseball game and I
went I probably bad at five six hundred
and you know the reason i sat out was
because you know that the Republicans
couldn't pay me enough attire oh hey let
me know the football show come on I'm on
this I want to come on the football show
with you sometimes well you know what
for governor governor Governor the
Browns gotta win a game and then I can
have you on okay okay so why not happy
on I might not have you on this season
where you're gonna win let us know when
you're in the neighborhood love to have
you back in the man cave how everybody
they're all the staff I said hi okay
Thank You governor that's Governor
Kasich the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience